[Music]
hey everyone welcome to Harry Potter
theory now we see it time and time again
Wizards operating all over the place
what a way to travel instantly getting
to wherever it is that you need to go or
before you can say hurry did you put
your neighbor to the cobbler fire
apparition is of course a magical means
of transportation akin to teleportation
where the user instantly travels from
one location to another but if this
method of transportation is so effective
why don't more witches and wizards
utilize it
why are you conventional and by
comparison far inferior methods of
transportation even exist for witches
and wizards cars come on okay so let's
get into the nitty-gritty first of all
it is a fairly advanced skill and not
all witches and wizards even know how to
do it secondly even if they do know how
to do it it's risky because it can be
tricky to pull off and then very badly
if botched thirdly many witches and
wizards simply prefer conventional means
of transport like brooms still pretty
cool flu powder connecting the fireface
Network and port keys enchanted objects
instantly transported you to a location
and lastly it is common knowledge that
most people vomit the first time they
operate even more than the first time
they see Ron Weasley's hair which makes
it slightly less appealing for a newbie
harry remarked that apparition felt like
being forced through a very tight rubber
tube one thing that I've always wondered
is why wizards don't use apparition to
travel long distances across countries
continents the world we only ever see or
hear of it being used for reasonable
trips my understanding of apparition is
it in order to operate you just need to
focus on the desired location in your
mind and that it's relatively
straightforward from
however JK rowling later expanded on the
practice of apparition on Twitter when
asked why Newt Scamander of fantastic
beasts took a boat to the USA instead of
operating her response was that
apparition becomes increasingly risky
over long distances namely because it
requires extensive knowledge of the
terrain - which one is moving and an
ability to visualize it clearly if you
aren't in the same country it's highly
unlikely that you're going to be able to
visualize the terrain appropriately
Rowling's summarize that
cross-continental apparition would
almost certainly result in severe injury
or death regardless of skill level
brooms flu powder port keys and magic
cards are all great but I know that I'd
be operating everywhere I hope you guys
enjoyed the video remember to leave your
video suggestions in the comment section
below also let me know which form of
transportation you'd use until next time
you're always arari
[Music]
you